thank you very much distinguished guests
from europe and beyond dear colleagues
and friends
welcome welcome to this very special
edition of the brussels economic forum
it is a special edition because for the
first time
all keynote speakers of this forum are
women
let me thank angela merkel jacinda
aldern
christine lagarde and all the speakers
for joining us today
and it's a special edition also because
europe's economy is
finally back on track and allow me to
start with a few numbers
in our spring economic forecast we
projected
our economy to grow by 4.2
this year and by 4.4 percent
in 2022 and the numbers
are looking better and better as we go
through the year
this means that in 18 months from now
all 27 member states
will be back on track recovered from the
crisis
no one expected this just a few months
ago
but it is not by chance this
is the result of the policy decisions we
took since the very early days of the
pandemic
and they have paid off and i would like
to mention two of them
the first is our work on vaccines
vaccination is now allowing our
countries and our economies to reopen
and the second factor is the
unprecedented
economic stimulus measures that we have
put together
at the european level and at the
national level
so to my first point our work on
vaccination
today more than sixty percent of
european adults have received
at least one shot and 41
are fully vaccinated and this is good
but we all know that we are not out of
the woods yet
we also have to support our neighbors
and we have to support the rest of the
world
because we will only be able to turn
this page
when we have reached immunity worldwide
now on my second point the economic
outlook
we have learned our lessons of the great
financial crisis of 2008.
so in the early days of this crisis
we immediately enabled member states to
take action
through the general escape clause for
example or through the temporary state
aid framework
and the full flexibilization of the eu
budget
and in parallel we worked on the first
european initiative
to finance short time work we called it
sure sure supported almost 30
million workers in europe last year
saving jobs and companies
and all that was about repairing now for
the long term the recovery
we also started working one year ago on
next generation eu
our package of 800 billion euro
in today's prices is the biggest
recovery package in europe since the
marshall plan
two weeks ago the commission issued
bonds to finance next generation eu
it was a big success seven times
oversubscribed
and with that we are ready to start
disbursing the pre-financing
in other words the funds will start
flowing to member states and
into our economy already in july
it's a first it's unprecedented
and it is precisely what europe needs
right now
because with next generation eu we are
reshaping our continent for decades
ahead
we're digitizing our economies as we've
never done before
and we are making the european green
deal a reality
we are equipping our societies to be
stronger
and to be more resilient
the impact of these investments will be
very tangible
next generation eu alone will boost our
economy
by 2 of gdp
but numbers only tell part of the story
the 800 billion euros from next
generation eu
are there to serve a purpose a vision of
the continent we want to build
we're not just bouncing back to
pre-crisis level
but we are bouncing forward into the
future
and in the last two weeks i have started
visiting our member states
and i have already seen what change next
generation
you can bring to our economies for
example in greece
next generation you will create 5g
corridors
and invest in high-speed broadband
infrastructure
to connect the whole country
or in denmark i visited an electrolyzer
that will use power from from windmills
and
biomass to produce clean hydrogen
and the project will receive funding
from next generation eu
and it will start producing clean
hydrogen by the end of the year
and it will fuel zero emission transport
in the copenhagen area or for example in
luxembourg
i met quantum experts who are working on
a new technology
for safe communications via satellite
and this will protect
our data flows from cyber attacks
and it is a project that can help create
jobs different jobs in many other eu
countries
and strengthen europe's tech sovereignty
these examples and many many more show
with next generation eu we are doing
more
than just increase our gdp
we are building a new economy digital
circular and sustainable
so this is just the beginning we have a
long
exciting road ahead of us next
generation you is
the recovery europe reads now and for
the future
so let's make it a success let's do that
together
and again thank you very much and again
welcome to the brussels economic forum